Salut, ici Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Mais bonjour tout le monde, excusez-moi pour cette interruption dans la publication des épisodes.
On s'est quittés il y a un peu plus d'un mois avec, voilà, l'interview de George-Louis Boucher, président anti-woke, puisqu'il avait terminé l'interview avec une longue tirade.
Il était parti en roue libre contre les wokistes et le : « On ne peut plus rien dire aujourd'hui », et cetera. Et voilà, j'étais resté un petit peu bouche bée face à ça et j'étais un petit peu gêné.
Je n'ai pas envie de transformer Septante Minutes Avec en match de boxe où je me bats contre mon invité. Donc j'avais laissé dire et j'étais un petit peu gêné de laisser dire.
Donc je vous propose aujourd'hui un regard tout autre, celui d'Alex Mahoudeau, sociologue et l'auteur du livre : « La Panique Woke, Anatomie d'une offensive réactionnaire ».
C'est parti. J'ai le plaisir aujourd'hui de recevoir Alex Mahoudeau. Alex Mahoudeau, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes docteur en sciences politiques, vous êtes sociologue.
Vous travaillez très régulièrement sur les questions liées aux polémiques qui entourent le politiquement correct et la, entre guillemets, la censure bien-pensante des campus.
Et c'est dans ce cadre-là que vous avez publié ce mois-ci un essai nommé : « La Panique Woke, Anatomie d'une offensive réactionnaire », publié aux Éditions Textuel.
Petite question à votre sujet avant qu'on se plonge donc au cœur des questions soulevées dans votre livre.
Mais qu'est-ce qui vous attire en fait dans, voilà, ces questions liées au « on ne peut plus rien dire » et au « c'était mieux avant » et au politiquement correct, et cetera, les questions que vous abordez dans votre livre.
Qu'est-ce qui vous attire vers ce sujet-là ?
Je dois avouer que c'est un objet qui, pour moi, au départ, est venu de façon un petit peu, comment dire, accidentelle, entre guillemets, qui est lié à ma vie.
Il s'avère que quand j'ai été étudier pour ma thèse qui porte pas du tout sur ces sujets-là au Royaume-Uni,
j'ai été assez rapidement confronté à une petite mobilisation sur le campus de l'université où j'étais,
qui était l'université de Durham à l'époque, où un monsieur avait été invité pour un débat de l'Union des étudiants, du club de débat, en fait, de l'université, assez prestigieux.
Et ce monsieur, c'était un député à l'époque européen qui s'appelle Godfrey Bloom et qui est un antiféministe assez radical.
Et donc notamment les associations féministes, en fait, du campus,
étaient scandalisées par le fait que le débat sur le féminisme de l'année soit consacré à un antiféministe et sur le thème de : « Nous vivons dans un monde désormais dominé par les femmes ».
Et donc avaient organisé une petite manifestation à laquelle j'ai participé. Y avait là quelques personnes. Et tout ça a été l'objet d'un petit peu un scandale,
sur le campus parce que les manifestantes et manifestants ont été accusés de s'en prendre à la liberté d'expression de ce monsieur.
Ce qui moi me surprenait beaucoup parce que Godfrey Bloom, c'était très facile de l'entendre parler sur ces sujets, même quand on en avait d'ailleurs pas envie.
Et donc, à partir de là, en fait, j'ai commencé à constater, à voir, comme l'ont vu beaucoup de personnes comme moi à cette époque, on était en 2014, 2015,
eh bien que cette question de la liberté d'expression sur les campus était très prévalente, revenait beaucoup.
Et donc à m'y intéresser et de fil en aiguille, à me rendre compte qu'il était jamais traité ou presque jamais traité de façon critique concernant, ben, les personnes qui s'en alarmaient.
Alors ça, c'était vrai au Royaume-Uni, c'était vrai aux États-Unis et je considère que c'est désormais vrai en France.
C'est-à-dire que moi, ce que j'essaye de faire à travers ce livre, c'est pas de répondre à la question : est-ce que le wokisme, ça existe, ça existe pas ?
Est-ce que c'est grave ou c'est pas grave ? Ça, à la limite, c'est quelque chose qui ne me concerne que de façon secondaire, mais d'essayer de comprendre les gens qui en parlent.
On va toucher à ça. Y a déjà énormément de sujets dans votre explication qui vont nous intéresser plus tard.
Je pense notamment à la question de la victimisation des personnes qui sont soi-disant censurées, alors qu'en fait, comme vous dites, on les entend très facilement.
On va toucher à ces questions-là un peu plus tard. Deuxième question à votre sujet. J'ai pas précisé, mais donc vous êtes également à la tête d'un compte Twitter très populaire, enfin relativement populaire.
C'est un petit peu votre entrée dans le, voilà, le discours public, les apparitions médiatiques avec ce livre.
Jusqu'à présent, vous étiez anonyme, caché derrière donc un pseudo sur Twitter. Comment est-ce que vous vivez cette transition ?
Est-ce quelque chose que vous faites facilement ? Est-ce que vous êtes déjà à l'aise dans cet exercice-là ou est-ce que c'est encore intimidant à ce stade ?
Alors ça, c'est intéressant parce que la popularité, entre guillemets, sur les réseaux sociaux, c'est quelque chose qui vient en réalité beaucoup par hasard.
Y a un effet d'accumulation. Beaucoup de gens suivent un compte parce que beaucoup de gens suivent un compte. Moi, pendant longtemps, mon compte était public et mon identité était connue.
Et en réalité, derrière mon pseudo, c'est en réalité assez facile de retrouver qui je suis, ce qui m'a d'ailleurs valu quelques petits messages parfois inquiétants.
Et la raison pour laquelle j'étais sous pseudonyme, moi, n'avait pas à voir avec la volonté de me protéger ou qu'on ne sache pas qui je suis,
mais de, en réalité, créer des bonnes conditions d'enseignement pour mes étudiants et mes étudiantes, puisque, à partir de 2018, en fait, j'ai commencé à prendre des charges de cours à l'université. Il m'a
estimé-- j'ai estimé que c'était important que les personnes face auxquelles j'allais me trouver
ne sachent pas de prime abord que je suis quelqu'un d'assez politisé, d'assez explicite dans ses orientations politiques,
pour qu'ils et elles aient la possibilité,
eh bien, de s'exprimer librement dans mes cours et qu'ensuite on en discute sans que ce soit, voilà, sans qu'il y ait un sentiment de nécessité d'autocensure ou de crainte ou d'intimidation qui leur pèse.
Donc moi, ma transition, entre guillemets, vers la vie publique, je la vis relativement bien. Forcément, c'est angoissant, mais pas plus qu'autre chose.
Et puis ben, c'est l'occasion d'avoir une conversation
autant que possible honnête autour de ces sujets. Et j'estime que, voilà, on peut ne pas être d'accord, surtout avec les personnes que je critique, sans que ça soit des personnes horribles que je voudrais envoyer dans un goulag
ou dans une prison de la pensée quelconque.
Mais, voilà, je pense que non, non, c'est une conversation qui a été jusqu'ici plutôt chouette.
Très bien, mais voilà. Mais comme ça, je suis rassuré, vous êtes à l'aise et c'est une bonne nouvelle. Commençons alors à nous plonger au cœur du sujet.
La Panique Woke, c'est donc le titre de votre livre. Ce que vous expliquez dans votre livre à plusieurs moments, c'est que quand on regarde les enquêtes d'opinion,
une information stable qui revient régulièrement, c'est qu'en fait, la plupart des gens n'ont jamais entendu parler de ce que c'est
être woke, ce que c'est le wokisme, entre guillemets, pour employer l'expression francisaise.
Du coup, je vais vous poser simplement la question pour, voilà, pour entamer la discussion. Qu'est-ce que c'est le wokisme, d'après vous ?
Alors d'après moi, c'est essentiellement une catégorie un peu fourre-tout-
Mh mh
...dans laquelle on va mettre globalement des gens qu'on n'aime pas. Des gens qu'on n'aime pas quand on est qui, des gens qu'on n'aime pas quand on est, disons, quand on va dans le sens d'une idéologie plutôt conservatrice.
Alors les gens qui parlent de wokisme, eux, vous diront que cette définition est très malhonnête et que le wokisme, c'est une idéologie bien comprise.
Mais, en les lisant, il me semble qu'ils ne font pas bien cet argument puisque eux-mêmes, en fait, ne sont pas d'accord sur ce que c'est.
Certains y voient l'effet du déploiement d'idéologies soi-disant postmodernes ou relativistes sur les campus américains depuis à peu près la deuxième moitié du XXe siècle.
D'autres y voient en fait un phénomène essentiellement psychologique qui viendrait d'une génération qui aurait trop été cocoonée par ses parents.
Et puis d'autres, enfin, y voient une forme d'action comme ça menée par le grand capital pour jeter un voile illusoire sur sa reprise en main de mouvements sociaux qui auraient pu potentiellement le critiquer.
Et d'autres aussi y voient une forme de retour du religieux, d'une sorte de religion qui se recréerait-
Mh mh
...et ce qui serait une innovation.
C'est un truc très, très dogmatique, finalement.
Ouais, tout à fait. Et donc, eh ben, c'est vu comme étant tout ça. Maintenant, moi, il me semble que c'est plus intéressant de le voir comme, voilà, cette espèce de catégorie fourre-tout.
Ouais, ouais. Et donc, un terme, d'après votre explication, plutôt péjoratif, plutôt employé par les détracteurs, ceux qui ont des positions plutôt conservatrices.
À l'origine, c'est un terme qu'on retrouvait plutôt dans les mouvements afro-américains, les mouvements qui, voilà, qui demandaient une certaine émancipation pour les personnes afro-américaines.
Et puis petit à petit,
ça s'est vraiment-- le terme a vraiment shifté. Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, on retrouve des personnes qui adoptent ce blason avec fierté et qui se disent : « Bah oui, moi, je suis woke » et qui le font avec fierté ?
Ou est-ce que c'est seulement dans la bouche des détracteurs, des conservateurs ?
Moi, je pense qu'on peut trouver, et notamment aux États-Unis où y a
un contrecoup au contrecoup, hein, y a pas mal de gens maintenant qui disent : « Bah au départ, woke, ça a une origine qui effectivement, comme vous l'avez dit, dans le mouvement des Noirs américains,
aux États-Unis, qui utilisent ce terme dans ce qu'on appelle l'African American Vernacular English,
pour décrire le fait d'être conscientisé sur la question des inégalités sociales, de la discrimination.
Et y a pas mal de gens qui disent : « Bah en fait, ce terme, entre guillemets, on nous en a dessaisi et nous, on va le reprendre pour le revendiquer.
Oui, il est fort possible de trouver, que ce soit aux États-Unis comme en France, des gens à qui on dit
: « Vous êtes des wokes » ou « Vous êtes des wokistes » et qui répondent en disant : « Ben ouais, en fait, c'est pas mal d'être la chose que vous décrivez, et donc y a pas de souci.
» Il me semble qu'on en trouve, ouais, bien sûr.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Alors, un argument très récurrent dans la bouche des détracteurs de ce, entre guillemets, ce soi-disant mouvement woke,
c'est l'idée que les universités sont corrompues, que ce sont des, voilà, des usines à penser, des usines à cerveaux où on leur inculque des notions d'intersectionnalité, etc.
Est-ce que c'est juste de dire ça ? Et est-ce que c'est un phénomène nouveau, cette accusation-là ?
Ce qui est juste, c'est de dire que, en tant que groupe social, les universitaires ont tendance à pencher plutôt à gauche dans leurs opinions politiques.
Ça, c'est effectivement relativement documenté.
Le fait de dire que c'est un problème me semble douteux. On sait par exemple qu'en tant que groupe professionnel, les médecins penchent plutôt à droite et personne n'y voit le moindre problème, alors même que
c'est des gens qui ont des décisions à prendre qui pourraient aussi être influencés par la politique, après tout.
Ce qui est faux, me semble-t-il,
c'est, ou en tout cas ce qui est exagéré, c'est le fait de penser que les universités produiraient comme ça,
une espèce de masse uniforme idéologiquement, qui ne changerait pas, qui conduirait comme ça à un changement radical de la société.
Déjà, tous les départements ne contiennent pas,
ne vont pas dans le même sens. Il me semble que personne ne s'inquiète du manque de diversité idéologique, par exemple, au sein des écoles de commerce qui ont tendance à pencher plutôt à droite ou des départements de droit.
Puis par ailleurs,
en fait, quand on regarde historiquement, les conservateurs ont eu peur de ça depuis très, très longtemps et depuis quasiment l'existence du mouvement conservateur,
on trouve des plumes, et pas des moindres, pour dire : « Attention, les lieux d'enseignement sont dominés par
les progressistes du jour et tout ça va nous créer une génération qui sera complètement endoctrinée et qui va se tourner vers une forme de radicalité politique.
» Et qu'est-ce qu'on constate ? J'ai presque envie de dire malheureusement, c'est que ce n'est pas le cas. Mais déjà dans les années, voilà, moi, je remonte aux années 50 aux États-Unis, on peut remonter plus anciennement en France.
Oui, y avait des gens pour dire ça et pour s'en inquiéter.
Un phénomène alors qui n'est pas si récent que ça, parce que c'est présenté comme étant quelque chose de très nouveau, de voilà.
En gros, ce qui est expliqué, c'est qu'aujourd'hui,
c'est toujours, hein, c'est cette idée qu'on ne peut plus rien dire, que tout le monde est très fragile, que si on n'est pas fragile, on s'inquiète pour la fragilité des autres et on les défend et on clame des nouvelles notions
d'appropriation culturelle, etc.
Parfois d'ailleurs, de manière assez abuseuse. Et ce que vous dites, c'est que finalement, ces
vagues-là d'universités, oui, qui penchent plutôt à gauche et qui, voilà, qui ont des discours qui déplaisent à certains groupes plutôt conservateurs.
En fait, c'est pas nouveau du tout et c'est quelque chose de récurrent. C'est ça que vous dites ?
Oui, complètement. C'est-à-dire que ben, si vous remontez par exemple voilà à la fin des années 50 aux États-Unis, vous avez
le grand intellectuel conservateur états-unien William Buckley qui va décrire dans son-- enfin au début des années 50, excusez-moi, je me suis trompé,
qui va décrire dans son livre God and Man at Yale un portrait de Yale qui est décrite quasiment comme étant une antre du communisme et de l'athéisme forcé,
où les professeurs feraient de la propagande socialiste non-stop et où ce serait impossible d'exprimer une opinion conservatrice,
même si Buckley lui-même a été président du journal de Yale à l'époque et a dirigé plusieurs clubs politiques également.
Et dans son livre, on trouve déjà cet aspect de dire : « Oh mon Dieu, c'est impossible d'avoir de la diversité idéologique sur les campus.
Il faut agir. » Il faut agir comment ? Il faut agir en se débarrassant des enseignants gauchistes. Et puis ça, on le retrouve ensuite ben, dans le courant des années 60, dans le courant des années 70 et ainsi de suite jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
On trouvait par exemple dans les années 90
une intellectuelle qui se présentait comme étant politiquement incorrecte, Camille Paglia, qui disait ben : « Moi, de mon temps, les universités, on pouvait y débattre de toutes sortes d'idées de façon très libertaire.
Et aujourd'hui, tout ça est verrouillé par le politiquement correct sur les campus. » Et ce qui est amusant, ça, je m'amuse à le faire,
c'est que quand on remonte à l'époque où Camille Paglia faisait ses humanités, eh ben on trouve des intellectuels un peu du même genre qu'elle qui disent : « Eh ben de mon temps, on pouvait avoir des débats à l'université, mais
aujourd'hui, eh bien
on ne peut plus parler de rien », car tout ça est dominé par ce qu'on appelait la culture adversariale qui était le politiquement correct de l'époque.
Donc, en fait, oui, y a un côté cyclique et répétitif et on a presque oublié, en fait, par manque, à mon avis aussi, d'études, ces vagues précédentes de scandalisation.
OK, ouais, c'est ça que j'allais aborder. C'est donc ce côté cyclique, mais la prétention aujourd'hui que c'est quelque chose de complètement nouveau, de jamais vu avant.
Et donc vous l'expliquez par un manque de documentation, un manque de travail d'historien, c'est ça ?
Alors, on a des auteurs très sérieux et très intéressants qui ont travaillé sur le sujet hein.
Moi, je cite beaucoup, par exemple, un historien qui m'a beaucoup intéressé, qui est Andrew Hartman, qui a écrit une histoire des guerres culturelles aux États-Unis.
On peut également citer le travail dans le livre French Theory. Alors là, le nom de l'auteur m'échappe, mais il se reconnaîtra.
Je lui demande pardon. On peut citer tout un tas d'auteurs et d'autrices comme ça, qui sont revenus hein, sur ces guerres culturelles.
C'est pas du tout un objet qui a été ignoré, loin s'en faut. Mais en ce qui concerne le débat, entre guillemets, mainstream-
Oui, le débat public, ouais
...eh bien force est de constater que oui, y a une prévalence complète d'un discours qui est toujours catastrophiste, toujours orienté vers le fait de dire que l'université est remplie de gauchistes qui veulent censurer tout le monde.
Alors que quand on regarde dans les faits, non, y a des débats qui ont lieu sans... Oui, les tempéraments peuvent monter.
Oui, y a des manifestations d'étudiants quand des personnes sulfureuses viennent à la fac, tout comme il y en a toujours eu.
Et d'ailleurs, c'est également le cas quand il y a des personnes de gauche hein, qui viennent. Les statistiques que je cite à ce niveau-là dans le bouquin, qui sont compilées par un chercheur canadien,
sur cette question, montrent bien que ben, dans la période qu'on estime comme étant la crise de la liberté d'expression aux États-Unis, c'est-à-dire 2015-2017,
en réalité, la majeure partie des personnes qui ont été licenciées ou qui n'ont pas vu leurs contrats se renouveler du fait de leurs opinions politiques, c'était en fait des personnes de gauche.
Je rappelle le titre de votre livre, La Panique Woke. On va s'intéresser donc précisément à ce chapitre-là plutôt qu'au chapitre, voilà, que vous évoquiez dans les années 50, 70 et ainsi de suite.
Et surtout la question de : mais à qui est-ce que ça bénéficie, cette panique woke ? Et pourquoi est-ce que ça prend autant de place dans le discours public alors que, je l'évoquais
en début d'émission, la plupart des gens ne savent pas ce que c'est.
Et pourtant, ça occupe énormément de place dans l'espace médiatique et même dans le discours politique. Alors, vous avez employé le mot il y a un instant de guerre culturelle.
Comment est-ce que vous définissez guerre culturelle ? Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Alors, les guerres culturelles, c'est une idée qui naît aux États-Unis dans les années 90, mais qui en réalité désigne un phénomène qui s'est déployé depuis bien plus longtemps,
qui consiste en fait à recadrer la politique états-unienne en disant : « Ben voilà, en fait, y a plus vraiment de gauche et de droite, en termes économiques notamment.
Ce qu'on a en revanche, c'est une opposition très nette entre, en gros, des centres urbains, libéraux sur le plan des mœurs, multiculturels, favorables aux droits des femmes, des minorités racisées, des personnes LGBT, etc.
» Et puis une autre partie de l'Amérique qui serait plus rurale, qui serait plus conservatrice sur le plan des mœurs, etc.
Et qu'en fait, ces deux États-Unis-là
ne pourraient pas se réconcilier. Et ça
a été repris beaucoup par le Parti républicain et à l'époque, dans la bouche d'une personne assez importante qui était Pat Buchanan,
qui a fait son grand discours, en fait, des guerres culturelles en disant : « Eh bien, c'est de là que vient le titre d'ailleurs du livre d'Andrew Hartman.
Il y a une guerre pour l'âme de l'Amérique et donc il va falloir la gagner. Et nous, on va se réorienter pour, en gros, mener la guerre politique sur le plan de la culture.
» Et en réalité, ce travail-là, il avait été fait depuis bien longtemps par le Parti républicain, notamment parce que le Parti républicain n'avait plus tellement de choses à proposer en termes d'améliorations concrètes de la vie des gens.
Donc, c'était intéressant de se tourner vers la question, eh ben voilà, de l'identité, des valeurs, des mesures qui sont présentées comme étant, voilà, dangereuses pour la civilisation, parce que ben sur ces choses-là, on peut proposer des choses.
Vous donnez un exemple très intéressant dans le livre d'un sondeur états-unien, Frank Luntz, qui était convaincu en juillet 2021 que
si on faisait un sondage en Grande-Bretagne pour savoir quelle était la plus grande division en Grande-Bretagne aujourd'hui,
lui était convaincu que la réponse de les woke contre les non-woke arriverait tout en haut et que ce serait le truc le plus important, donc cette fameuse, voilà, guerre culturelle qu'on évoquait il y a un instant.
Et en fait, finalement, c'est arrivé bien après les riches contre les pauvres, les Britanniques natifs contre les immigrants, les élites contre les gens ordinaires et ainsi de suite.
Donc finalement, cette préoccupation déjà, alors je ne sais pas si c'est la même situation aux États-Unis, mais quand on regarde le résultat de ce sondage-là, ça donne l'impression que ces guerres culturelles,
c'est une préoccupation très artificielle et qui
intéresse assez peu monsieur, madame Tout-le-Monde.
Est-ce que c'est juste ?
Alors, c'est même plus, c'est presque pire, entre guillemets, que ce que vous avez dit. C'est-à-dire que monsieur Luntz n'avait pas cette intuition avant de faire son sondage, il l'avait après.
C'est-à-dire qu'il avait mené effectivement une campagne, c'est pas seulement un sondeur hein, c'est également un spin doctor et un conseiller politique proche du Parti républicain.
Et donc ce monsieur avait mené une enquête d'opinion, effectivement, sur l'opinion, un peu pour voir un peu toute l'opinion politique des Britanniques.
Et ce qui est intéressant, c'est que le rendu médiatique de son petit travail,
c'était de dire : « Eh bien voilà, ce sondeur montre que le wokisme, c'est le premier problème », alors qu'effectivement, il arrivait très très loin derrière d'autres sujets.
Alors, est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui n'intéresse pas monsieur et madame Tout-le-Monde ? Oui, si on regarde les enquêtes d'opinion et oui, si on regarde, ben, en fait, ce pourquoi les gens, par exemple en France, ont voté cette année.
Et ça, ça désespère beaucoup mes anti-woke. Vous avez des gens qui sont partis, par exemple, en croisade.
On peut citer plusieurs chroniques de l'éditorialiste canadien Mathieu Bock-Côté en France, sur Europe 1 et sur CNews.
Ouais, ouais, qui est un peu le monsieur anti-woke en France hein, qui est donc importé, comme vous le disiez, du Québec.
Et c'est, ouais, c'est un visage très récurrent quand on s'intéresse à ces sujets.
Ouais, ouais, et puis qui, avant ça, était monsieur anti-multiculturalisme et monsieur anti-racisme et monsieur anti-islamo-gauchisme. Enfin-
C'est ça, c'est ça, ouais.
...il a un champ de compétences assez large. Et donc ce monsieur, dans le cadre de ses chroniques à Europe 1 et sur CNews,
s'atterrait complètement du fait que le débat public partait autour de l'élection présidentielle dans le sens du pouvoir d'achat plutôt que de l'identité de la France.
Pascal Praud a tenu des propos un peu similaires récemment. Et donc là, on voit en fait cette opposition qui est de dire : « Ben non, en fait, il faut pas qu'on débatte, il faut pas que notre débat politique soit axé autour de
combien d'argent vous avez à la fin du mois dans votre,
portefeuille et quelles sont vos conditions de travail, quel type de vie vous pouvez mener avec ça, mais doit s'axer autour de : est-ce qu'on va retirer les statues de Colbert ?
Est-ce qu'on va renommer les rues de noms de personnages issus de minorités ? Est-ce qu'on va finalement respecter la grande geste historique française ?
» Et moi, j'ai pas de problème avec le fait qu'il y ait une idéologie qui veuille qu'on fonctionne comme ça. Pas du tout.
Mais dans ce cas-là, disons-le, disons c'est une position politique. Y en a qui veulent qu'on débatte sur la base de conditions matérielles de la vie des gens
et d'autres qui veulent qu'on discute sur la base de : est-ce que le roman national français va être respecté ?
Puis sur cette base-là, chacun prendra ensuite ses options.
Ce décalage entre donc les électeurs, monsieur, madame Tout-le-Monde et donc les personnes que vous avez citées, donc qui sont des personnalités médiatiques en haut de la pyramide, pour ainsi dire,
c'est un décalage très intéressant et on va continuer à en discuter.
Ce que vous dites dans le livre, c'est : toutes les personnes s'inquiétant du wokisme ne sont pas réactionnaires, loin s'en faut, mais presque toutes les personnes adhérant à des idéologies réactionnaires veulent que vous vous inquiétiez du wokisme.
Oui.
Et c'est en fin de compte probablement à ça que sert ce mot. Donc oui, je vais vous poser la question : comment expliquer une telle passion pour ces enjeux alors que monsieur, madame Tout-le-Monde s'en fiche ?
Ben,
déjà, rien ne nous dit qu'il n'est pas possible d'avoir une certaine influence politique en agitant des sujets qui n'intéressent pas fondamentalement la majorité, entre guillemets, de la population.
Déjà, c'est possible de créer des minorités actives. Pensons par exemple à la place qu'a tenue dans le mouvement conservateur aux États-Unis,
la question de l'avortement, de la suppression, de la réduction autant que possible du droit à l'avortement qui a conduit
récemment à une décision, en tout cas une décision qui semble aller dans le sens du renversement de l'arrêt,
de la jurisprudence Roe vs Wade, qui garantit le droit à l'avortement aux États-Unis.
Eh bien, en fait, la majorité des citoyens des États-Unis sont favorables au droit à l'avortement,
mais il y a une minorité active suffisamment intéressée et suffisamment engagée qui vote spécifiquement autour de cette question, qui fait que c'est une bonne base de militantisme.
Ensuite, c'est possible d'influencer des gens qui sont déjà au pouvoir. On parle du wokisme. Certes, au moment où le wokisme apparaît dans l'espace public français, il n'intéresse pas la majorité des Français.
Par contre, des gens qui l'intéressent beaucoup, c'est des personnes qui sont au gouvernement. Par exemple, Jean-Michel Blanquer, qui va créer une institution censée, un laboratoire de la République, censée lutter contre ce truc-là.
Ou alors des candidats à l'élection présidentielle, etc. Des députés qui vont organiser des débats parlementaires sur la question et qui donc vont en fait tenter de légiférer.
Que la majorité de la population s'y intéresse ou pas n'est pas la question. Dans la mesure où nous sommes dans une démocratie représentative, c'est ce qui intéresse les élus qui est important.
Par ailleurs, moi, je pense pas qu'il faille penser qu'il y a là un complot, en fait, des élites contre le peuple qui veulent créer des diversions.
En fait, y a là un fonctionnement de la machine médiatique et une machine à scandalisation qui est très réceptive à des stratégies d'influence conçues au sein de ce qu'on a appelé à une époque la nouvelle droite,
et qui a pour but en fait d'influencer la politique par la culture.
Et donc qui va produire des intellectuels, produire des essais, produire des thèses qui vont ensuite pouvoir être mobilisés.
Et ça, c'est du militantisme en réalité hein, il faut le reconnaître comme tel.
Mh. Et je pense comprendre, en lisant votre livre, qu'il y a aussi un facteur de la nature des médias et des chaînes d'info continue aujourd'hui.
C'est-à-dire qu'y a une forme de ce que vous appelez une mobilisation médiatique, mais ce sont des problèmes qui sont aussi très,
comment dire, très stimulants, très excitants, très sensationnalistes, beaucoup plus que, oui, la question du pouvoir d'achat.
Est-ce que c'est pas un facteur aussi, le fait que, voilà, les différentes rédactions de presse, les différentes chaînes d'infos
sont en concurrence, cherchent de l'audience et donc cherchent des sujets beaucoup plus excitants, beaucoup plus saisissants que, voilà, les enjeux comme, oui, le pouvoir d'achat, par exemple.
Est-ce que ça fait pas partie du problème aussi ?
Alors, y a une grammaire médiatique qui doit être respectée, évidemment. Moi, je cite un travail qui s'appelle La Banlieue du 20 heures, qui est une ethnographie du fonctionnement du journal télévisé de France 2,
pendant les années 2000,
me semble-t-il, et qui montre comment des discours stéréotypés sur la
banlieue en France ne viennent pas du fait que les journalistes ou même les cadres de la télévision publique aient adopté des images, des perceptions négatives de ces personnes-là,
mais vraiment vient des conditions de travail et des normes professionnelles qui se répandent, du fait qu'il faut produire de l'information de plus en plus vite dans un milieu qui est compétitif.
Et donc, on a, ben, un peu les habitués, on a les personnes qui viennent facilement à la télévision, on a aussi les sujets qui sont faciles à faire, et cetera, et cetera.
Et par conséquent, l'information se produit, entre guillemets, toute seule, presque indépendamment de ce qu'en pensent les gens qui la font.
Par ailleurs, effectivement, y a cette question de la scandalisation. Mais il faut bien prendre en compte que tout objet médiatique peut se scandaliser.
Vous avez par exemple, sur la question du pouvoir d'achat, des formes de scandalisation qui ont lieu, hein, en ce moment.
On va voir que certains produits vont devenir comme ça un objet de fixation particulière. Alors, on pense beaucoup à l'huile en ce moment en France parce que c'est un objet qui, enfin c'est une denrée qui commence à
voir un peu son prix augmenter. Mais,
bon, si vous avez étudié le monde arabe comme moi, vous savez que les révolutions arabes au début des années 2010, dans un certain nombre de pays, par exemple en Égypte, ont entre autres commencé à cause de l'augmentation du prix du pain,
qui était comme ça un objet qui créait un scandale public et qui permettait une mobilisation très forte.
Donc, je pense pas que par nature, les baba cool sur le campus de la fac de lettres soient un objet plus scandaleux que n'importe quel autre, mais c'est une question de traitement.
Oui, tout à fait. Donc y a une--
les termes dont on parle, wokisme intersectionnel, et cetera, qui-- le terme intersectionnel,
au demeurant n'est pas un terme péjoratif, n'est pas un terme sale, mais comme vous dites, c'est une question de traitement puisque ce sont des termes qui sont employés
de façon quasi automatique sur le, voilà, à travers le prisme du danger ou de la menace.
Ouais, tout à fait. Et qui sont des termes qui, à l'origine, n'ont rien de rebutant.
Débattre de la question de l'intersectionnalité, donc pour le dire simplement, l'intersectionnalité, c'est une théorie au départ juridique
qui vise à décrire le fait que des conditions particulières émergent au croisement de plusieurs discriminations.
En gros, les problèmes des femmes noires ne sont pas tout à fait les problèmes des femmes, pas tout à fait les problèmes des personnes noires. Et donc
c'est des problèmes qui leur sont spécifiques. Au départ, ça permettait de faire face à des conditions d'inégalité de traitement face aux questions, notamment des violences sexuelles, dont étaient spécifiquement victimes ces personnes-là
dans des associations où, en gros, quand elles étaient dans des associations de femmes, on leur disait : « Ben non, en fait, c'est un problème de racisme que vous décrivez là.
» Et quand elles étaient dans des organisations plutôt noires, on leur disait : « Non, là, c'est un problème de femmes. » Et donc elles avaient pas tellement lieu où s'exprimer.
Au départ, c'est ça.
On peut en discuter et y a des enjeux tout à fait intéressants à discuter. Par exemple, une enquête qui a été menée par un groupe qui n'est pas particulièrement
socialiste révolutionnaire, l'Institut Montaigne, me semble-t-il, montrait que, eh bien, si vous êtes
un homme identifié comme musulman en France, vous allez avoir un certain type de discrimination à l'embauche par rapport au fait de savoir si vous êtes une femme identifiée comme musulmane ou un homme identifié comme chrétien, et cetera.
Bon, on peut tout à fait discuter de ces choses-là. En revanche, ce qui s'est passé, c'est pas ça. Ce qui s'est passé, c'est qu'on a sorti ce terme, on lui a fait dire tout et n'importe quoi.
On en a fait en fait l'identifiant d'un groupe de personnes qu'on a appelé les néo-féministes intersectionnelles,
pour ne pas dire les méchantes qu'on n'aime pas, et dit : « Voilà, ces dames-là, elles ont des débats qui sont abstraits, qui sont absurdes, elles font des mauvaises choses et donc c'est des méchantes et des personnes à dénoncer.
» Rokhaya Diallo, par exemple, est une personne de cette nature.
C'est ça. Voilà. De nombreuses personnes qui ont été invitées dans Septante Minutes Avec reçoivent des qualificatifs de ce type dans les commentaires et dans les messages privés, je ne vous le cache pas.
Nous les saluons.
Exactement, ben voilà, dont Rokhaya Diallo, par exemple. Au risque de me répéter, je voudrais vous demander alors, mais qu'est-ce qui explique la nature disproportionnée de la couverture de ces guerres culturelles ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on en parle autant ?
Eh ben, pour citer Pierre Bourdieu, j'ai fait le sociologue une seconde, on en parle autant parce qu'on en parle autant.
On en parle autant parce que c'est un objet qui émerge, qui est légitime, qui est légitimé, qui est mis en avant. Et par conséquent, il faut en parler parce qu'il faut en parler.
C'est ce que Bourdieu appelait la circularité circulaire de l'information, avec ce sens de la formule qui était le sien.
On en parle parce qu'on en parle, en fait. On en parle parce que ça fait le buzz sur Twitter, parce que ça a été évoqué dans un article, parce que ça a été évoqué dans un autre journal, et cetera, et cetera.
C'est très circulaire, ça, puisque le buzz est justement produit par ces émissions-là, par ces rédactions-là.
Oui, donc là, y a un côté effectivement cyclique. Et il faut bien prendre en compte aussi que,
eh ben, y a aussi un groupe d'acteurs que moi, je décris en tant que groupe, j'essaye pas de faire comme d'autres ont pu faire des parcours individuels, ça, ça m'intéresse pas trop,
qui sont des intellectuels publics et qui ont toujours plus ou moins un livre à vendre,
toujours plus ou moins un film à vendre, toujours plus ou moins quelque chose à dire sur ce qui se passe et qui vont produire de la théorie comme ça très rapidement, de façon
assez efficace pour un plateau de grands médias et qui vont pouvoir donner leur avis un petit peu sur tout, et surtout sur des affaires qui
sont facilement distordables parce que personne va tellement regarder ce qui s'est vraiment passé et puis qui sont facilement-- donc qu'on peut facilement monter en épingle.
Il suffit en fait que quelques tweets aient été faits sur le fait que dans tel film, y a eu une représentation raciste ou ce que vous voulez.
Et puis très vite, ça peut devenir un objet médiatique qui va être présenté comme étant tel film est cancelled, a été annulé à cause de la lutte contre le racisme et les racismes ont trop-- les antiracistes vont trop loin.
Et voilà. Donc tout ça, c'est facile à monter en épingle, en fait, ça fait vite un sujet.
Mh, mh, mh. Je vais revenir sur, donc voilà, vous l'avez dit à plusieurs reprises qu'il ne s'agit pas donc d'un complot de réactionnaires malveillants qui tireraient dans l'ombre les ficelles du débat public.
malgré ça, la question de
La situation de CNews pose question, puisque donc je rappelle que ça a été racheté il y a quelques années par
le multimilliardaire Vincent Bolloré, qui donc soutient, ou en tout cas sa famille soutient, pour être plus exact, financièrement la campagne d'Éric Zemmour.
Quand on assemble ces éléments ensemble,
on est tenté de se dire : « Mais tiens, mais ce groupe Canal+ a nettement, nettement penché à droite et a repris énormément les sujets, les couvertures de ces questions de guerre culturelle depuis
le rachat par Vincent Bolloré.
Est-ce que c'est une coïncidence ou est-ce qu'il y a justement complot ? Est-ce qu'il y a tirage de ficelles dans l'ombre ?
Eh bien, je pense que ça, c'est une question à laquelle doivent répondre les gens qui enquêtent sur-
D'accord.
...sur l'empire médiatique de Vincent Bolloré. Y a par exemple vos collègues de Les Jours qui font ce travail de longue date, qui ont l'air d'indiquer que oui, ça a l'air d'être plutôt le cas.
Y a évidemment d'autres journalistes qui font ce travail. Moi, je ne suis pas dans le secret des dieux, je ne sais pas ce qui se passe dans la tête de cette personne et donc je me contente de regarder ce à quoi j'ai accès.
Et ce à quoi j'ai accès, c'est le fait que effectivement, on a,
encore une fois, sur ces plateformes-là médiatiques, un certain nombre effectivement d'acteurs idéologiques qui ont été-- qui se sont substitués en fait hein, au traitement de l'information.
Et on a en fait beaucoup plus un modèle qui ressemble à celui de Fox News, où c'est une chaîne-
Ouais, tout à fait.
...d'information qui est une chaîne d'opinion, en fait, qui est une chaîne sur laquelle on entend beaucoup parler des gens, de ce qu'ils pensent.
Et c'est pas mal hein, l'opinion, ça n'est pas un problème, mais il faut bien comprendre que c'en est.
Ça, ça coûte pas très cher à produire et ça a surtout un effet sur les discours politiques en France et aux États-Unis.
Oui.
J'vais-- mais donc voilà, j'aimerais alors nuancer un petit peu la réponse qu'on apportait sur le, est-ce qu'il s'agit de complots, de personnes malveillantes qui tirent les ficelles dans l'ombre.
Votre réponse, c'est non, a priori, de manière générale, la plupart du temps non. Mais donc on peut se poser des questions sur certaines rédactions et vous dites : « Je laisse les journalistes enquêter à ce sujet.
» Est-ce que je résume bien ?
Ouais, c'est ça. Et presque, j'ai envie de dire, que ce soit le cas ou non, quelle importance ? Mettons que ça en soit.
Mettons que toutes les personnes qui veulent parler de wokisme se retrouvent en fait dans un-
Pas toutes, mais certaines.
...dans un dîner pour se mettre d'accord, que certaines se retrouvent pour se mettre d'accord. Le problème, de mon point de vue n'est pas que ce soit le cas.
Ces gens ont le droit d'être d'accord entre eux. Ils auraient même le droit de se coordonner. Enfin, c'est tout à fait légitime.
Encore une fois, c'est complètement de la fiction ce que je suis en train de dire, mais le problème, c'est qu'il y a la possibilité de le faire, à mon avis.
C'est pour ça que moi, je m'intéresse plutôt au fait qu'on a des médias qui sont concentrés, on a des médias qui travaillent d'une certaine façon, et qui permettent l'émergence de ce truc-là.
Ensuite, que ce soit un complot malveillant ou pas, moi, je ne sais pas et je n'en ai cure.
D'accord, oui, OK. C'est pas le cœur du problème. Je comprends bien ce que vous dites. J'vais revenir donc à-- puisque là, on discutait des auteurs de ces positions anti-woke.
Je vais revenir au fond du discours et analyser les propos qui sont donnés dans ces circonstances-là.
Un élément récurrent que vous avez évoqué dans votre exemple en début d'interview, c'est
la posture de la victime. En gros, la personne dans votre université qui,
voilà, qui ne pouvait pas s'exprimer publiquement, c'est une victime, alors qu'on l'entend très facilement un peu partout, et c'est vraiment une victime de l'injustice, etc.
Pourquoi en fait ? Pourquoi est-ce qu'on retrouve aussi régulièrement cette idée de se poser en victime ?
Alors, si on croit un politologue qui a travaillé sur ce qu'il appelle l'esprit réactionnaire
en Europe et aux États-Unis, Corey Robin, c'est lié au fait que, eh bien, la victimisation, en réalité, c'est une forme rhétorique classique de l'idéologie réactionnaire.
Lui, il prend l'exemple d'une personne comme Edmund Burke, déjà bien, y a bien longtemps, qui écrivait des textes très, bah très victimaires sur ce qui était arrivé à Marie-Antoinette pendant la Révolution française, etc.
Et effectivement, on trouve une forme de victimisation qui est généralement assez,
assez peu perçue comme telle chez les intellectuels conservateurs ou réactionnaires, qui va consister à se victimiser comme étant la personne qui a perdu un monde idéal.
Autrefois, les gens qui méritaient d'aller en haut allaient en haut et les gens qui méritaient d'aller en bas allaient en bas.
Et tout était bien comme ça et les vaches étaient bien gardées. Et aujourd'hui, à cause des interventions des méchants progressistes, le monde n'est plus comme ça, tout a été renversé sur sa tête et nous, nous sommes les nouvelles victimes.
Ce qui m'intéresse, c'est qu'il y a une contradiction dans les termes entre des gens qui, en tant qu'intellectuels,
font une partie de leur métier en dénonçant
les passions victimaires,
le fait que de nos jours, les femmes, les musulmans, les personnes LGBT, les minorités de tout poil, les syndicalistes et qui voulez-vous passeraient leur temps à se victimiser pour obtenir des passe-droits.
Et le fait que eux-mêmes, ces intellectuels conservateurs, passent aussi leur temps à se victimiser et à arriver à la conclusion de dire : « Eh bien ma foi, il nous faudrait des passe-droits.
» Cette crainte sur les campus universitaires d'une domination de l'idéologie de gauche a conduit
ces intellectuels à demander des mesures de ce qu'on appelle la discrimination positive, qui s'appelle aux États-Unis l'action affirmative, en faveur des personnes de droite.
C'est-à-dire de dire : « Eh bien, les départements de sciences sociales devraient embaucher un certain quota de personnes conservatrices, pour qu'on ait égalité sur ce domaine.
» Alors que si on commence à en parler dans d'autres domaines, ils vont dire : « Bah non, c'est le jeu de la méritocratie. »
Alors qu'on n'observe pas le contraire. On n'observe pas les demandes de parties plutôt placées à gauche, de absolument poser des pions gauchistes, wokistes dans les milieux plutôt marqués à droite.
Ça, c'est pas quelque chose qu'on observe. Donc y a une asymétrie à ce niveau-là.
Un autre concept dont vous parlez dans votre livre, c'est le concept de panique morale que vous n'inventez pas, mais qui est déjà bien connu en sociologie.
De quoi s'agit-il exactement ?
Alors une panique morale, c'est un phénomène médiatique essentiellement, qui est constitué par cinq éléments principaux.
D'abord un élément de malaise. Il y a le sentiment qu'il se passe quelque chose de négatif dans une société ou une partie d'une société donnée.
Ensuite, un sentiment d'hostilité orienté vers un groupe qui est rendu responsable de ce malaise. Donc c'est les méchants wokistes, les baba cool de la fac de lettres ou autres.
Troisièmement, il y a une forme de consensus, c'est-à-dire au moins un groupe de cette société donnée pense que ce malaise est justifié et que—
C'est du bon sens.
...voilà, que c'est du bon sens et qu'on ne peut pas en remettre en question l'existence de ce problème.
Quatrièmement, y a une dimension de volatilité. Tout ça apparaît très vite et disparaît très vite, parfois sans laisser de traces. Et enfin—
C'est ça, une polémique autour d'une petite phrase et puis on en parle plus cinq jours après.
C'est ça, tout à fait. On n'a pas parlé de galette des rois cette année, on a parlé de galette des rois et des reines.
Et puis ça va durer six jours et puis au bout de six jours, plus personne n'en entend parler.
Sur Fox News aussi, chaque année, y a le The War Against Christmas. Parce que les—
Exactement.
...les woke préfèrent dire Happy Holidays plutôt que Merry Christmas. Et donc—
Tout à fait. Oui, c'est ça, tout à fait. Et qui remonte à longtemps hein, c'était quelque chose dont l'industriel et antisémite notoire Henry Ford accusait déjà les Juifs au début du 20e siècle,
de vouloir supprimer Noël en ne disant plus Merry Christmas.
Et cinquièmement, le cinquième élément donc, c'est la disproportion. C'est-à-dire qu'on a des affaires qui sont soit relativement anodines, soit relativement anodines par rapport à d'autres.
C'est-à-dire ça peut concerner des gens à qui il arrive des choses qui sont effectivement graves, mais qui sont graves à même hauteur que plein d'autres trucs sont graves et dont on parle de façon disproportionnée par rapport à ce qu'il
s'est passé.
Un exemple, c'est que la première panique morale qui a été étudiée en tant que telle, qui était
les guerres des gangs entre les mods et les rockers au Royaume-Uni dans les années 60, eh bien, en fait, avait créé des dégâts qui étaient décrits comme étant : « Ils détruisent la ville, la ville est en
sens dessus dessous et une chatte n'y retrouverait pas ses
petits », alors qu'en réalité, c'est simplement quelques chaises et quelques matériels, quelques vitres et quelques matériaux urbains qui avaient été cassés, comme
ça peut être le cas dans une grande bagarre de rue.
Inquiétant, mais pas dramatique au point de dire que l'avenir du Royaume-Uni était remis en cause. Donc c'est ça une panique morale.
Et ce concept a été utilisé ensuite pour décrire tout un ensemble de phénomènes
et a été beaucoup utilisé aux États-Unis, un petit peu en France, pour décrire, voilà, des inquiétudes comme ça, qui sont nées, qui ont explosé pendant un temps, puis qui ont disparu en laissant
relativement peu ou pas de traces explicites.
Ce que vous expliquez dans le livre, c'est que ces paniques morales ne sont pas manufacturées, ne sont pas créées à partir de rien, mais elles sont caractérisées par la construction de problèmes publics.
Ouais.
Est-ce que vous avez des exemples de ça ?
Oui, personne ne peut créer un phénomène médiatique à partir de rien. Les médias, c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça.
On n'a pas quelqu'un qui est capable de comme ça mentir, même si parfois on imagine que c'est le cas. Y a toujours quelque chose qu'on peut monter en épingle hein.
Un exemple de panique morale qui n'est pas venue de rien, mais qui est devenue n'importe quoi, ben c'est—
C'est déjà ça la disproportion dont vous parlez, ouais.
Exactement. C'est ce qu'on a appelé la panique satanique aux États-Unis. À l'origine de la panique satanique, qui est un moment
de très grande inquiétude sur le fait qu'il y aurait des groupes satanistes qui traverseraient les États-Unis et qui enlèveraient, agresseraient sexuellement,
assassineraient des enfants, notamment dans le cadre de cérémonies
sanglantes et très effrayantes.
À l'origine de cette panique, y a une réalité qui est que,
on a pris conscience aux États-Unis que les violences sexuelles, notamment faites aux enfants, c'était un vrai problème et que longtemps, en fait, ce problème avait été passé sous silence parce qu'on n'écoutait pas les victimes.
Et puis, qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Il s'est passé que, ben, un certain nombre de cas ont été comme ça fortement grossis ou alors des rumeurs ont été exagérées.
Des parents ont fortement insisté auprès de leurs enfants pour que ceux-ci leur relatent des faits qui ne s'étaient pas nécessairement produits.
Et de fil en aiguille, l'idée que, voilà, c'était des étrangers qui venaient faire ces choses parce qu'on pouvait pas accuser la bonne famille américaine.
Faut savoir que les violences sexuelles faites aux mineurs, majoritairement, ont lieu de la part d'un ou d'une proche de la victime, généralement d'un proche de la victime.
Eh ben, pour rejeter en fait cette idée qu'au sein de la famille comme ça hétérosexuelle pouvait se cacher quelque chose d'horrible,
on a inventé des méchants satanistes et tout ça a conduit à des grands procès, d'abord médiatiques, puis juridiques, qui souvent n'ont conduit à rien.
Et puis tout ça est retombé. Et aujourd'hui, quand on parle de la panique satanique aux États-Unis, tout le monde se regarde un peu avec un air bizarre en se disant : « C'est vrai que c'était très étrange cette histoire »,
alors même que le phénomène est en train de se reproduire autour de QAnon, par exemple.
Et donc, ouais, tout à fait. J'allais faire le parallèle. On peut donc retrouver tous les éléments que vous avez cités.
Donc côté très hostile, très volatile, éphémère, disproportionné, quelque chose de très collectif hein, puisque comme vous le disiez, c'était pas une petite minorité, c'était très omniprésent aux États-Unis.
Et effectivement, j'allais faire la comparaison aujourd'hui avec toutes les histoires de pizzeria, avec des opérations pédophiles dans un sous-sol, soi-disant sous-sol qui n'existe pas, l'histoire de QAnon, etc.
Donc c'est quelque chose de très présent aujourd'hui. J'ai envie de vous poser la question de la disproportion, de monter une affaire en épingle.
Il y a 40, 50 ans, c'était donc très fort lié, entre autres choses, mais très fort lié aux médias traditionnels.
Aujourd'hui, QAnon, c'est surtout les réseaux sociaux et des réseaux peut-être un peu plus alternatifs.
Donc y a eu un changement à ce niveau-là, au niveau de la croissance, l'évolution de ces paniques morales.
Y a eu une interpénétration de ces deux secteurs. Là-dessus, on touche au fait que en sciences sociales, nos concepts ne sont jamais complètement hermétiques les uns aux autres.
Et par exemple, faire la distinction entre une panique morale et une rumeur est difficile.
L'une des paniques morales citées comme telle par exemple Goode et Ben-Yehuda, qui sont les deux sociologues que je cite le plus sur ce sujet,
c'est ce qu'on a appelé la rumeur d'Orléans, qui était une rumeur antisémite qui s'est répandue sans besoin de s'appuyer sur les médias,
notamment à Orléans dans les années 60.
Et là, on voyait effectivement l'effet du bouche-à-oreille complètement et pas du tout de relatement dans les journaux, par exemple.
On retrouve ce type de phénomène. Faut comprendre que les médias sociaux, les réseaux sociaux, bah ils fonctionnent en fonction des mêmes règles globalement, hein, que l'ensemble des interactions sociales.
Donc oui, y a des rumeurs qui s'y répandent, y a des gens qui créent des
organismes qu'on appelle de réinformation, qui vont distordre, sélectionner, découper,
modifier, parfois inventer complètement l'information et qui vont, ben, servir de base effectivement à la diffusion de rumeurs et de panique morale.
Mais néanmoins, les médias traditionnels restent quand même très présents. Effectivement, QAnon et toutes ces histoires de pédophilie, etc., aux États-Unis se développent via les réseaux sociaux, etc.
Mais si on regarde la grande panique transphobe qui a lieu en ce moment et anti-LGBT qui a lieu en ce moment aux États-Unis, elle s'appuie sur qui ?
Elle s'appuie, bah, de nouveau sur Fox News, sur le New York Post, sur des groupes comme ça qui sont des grands groupes médiatiques légitimes.
Donc c'est important effectivement de prendre en compte les médias sociaux, c'est important de prendre en compte les médias traditionnels dans la façon dont les deux fonctionnent ensemble.
Oui, oui, oui. Et donc, pour revenir au sujet principal, ce moment de wokisme, cette panique woke, puisque c'est le titre de votre livre.
Les effets politiques de cette panique woke, puisqu'on parlait du fait que c'était éphémère et que c'était disproportionné et que ça durait cinq jours et puis on oublie.
Est-ce qu'il faut donc en déduire que la panique woke, ça n'a aucune importance, c'est éphémère et puis on oublie ?
En ce moment en France, on en a presque l'impression. Quelqu'un me faisait la réflexion hier que : « Dis donc, tu marques dans ton livre que ça se trouve, on parlera plus de wokisme quand tu sortiras ton bouquin.
» Et c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé parce qu'effectivement, là pour le moment, ça a l'air d'être un peu retombé, ce soufflé-là, pour le moment.
Alors, ça vivote toujours un petit peu, mais bon, quand même beaucoup moins. Y a des effets, à mon avis, sous au moins deux aspects.
D'abord, y a des mesures qui sont prises. Y a eu
un précédent qui a été ouvert
dans le cadre de cette panique autour du wokisme et précédemment de l'islamo-gauchisme en France,
qui est un précédent dans lequel un ou une ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et de la Recherche peut demander à des institutions publiques, alors là, ça lui a été refusé, peut-être que la prochaine fois, ça ne le sera pas,
de réaliser une enquête idéologique sur le monde de la recherche en France.
Ça, c'est un précédent qui est dangereux parce que, ben, maintenant que ça a été fait, ça va pouvoir se refaire. Une deuxième façon dont y a de l'influence, eh ben, c'est à travers la création d'institutions.
Le fameux Laboratoire de la République de Jean-Michel Blanquer, maintenant, il existe. Alors, combien de temps il va exister ?
Est-ce qu'il va se transformer en autre chose, etc. ? J'en sais rien, mais il existe. Des groupes comme par exemple,
je cite le soi-disant Observatoire du décolonialisme, qui est en réalité un réseau informel de chercheurs qui ont un blog, hein, c'est autant un observatoire que vous et moi,
eh bien, existe également et a été crédité d'une forme de crédibilité par un ministre, là encore, Jean-Michel Blanquer, qui s'est rendu pour faire l'ouverture
de leur prétendu colloque, qui était en fait une causerie organisée par une petite association au sein de la Sorbonne.
Donc ça, ça a des effets. En fait, ça reste. Outre l'imaginaire collectif, le fait que voilà, maintenant, wokisme, c'est— j'ai vu que c'était rentré dans un des dictionnaires de la langue française.
Très bien, y a pas de souci, c'est comme ça que fonctionnent les dictionnaires. Et donc maintenant, est un terme qui va être beaucoup plus légitimé, qui va survivre au fur et à mesure des années.
Est-ce qu'on observe des phénomènes de récupération par— ben voilà, vous avez donné plein d'exemples, notamment Jean-Michel Blanquer en France.
Est-ce qu'y a pas l'idée, quand on observe ces récupérations par des personnalités politiques, de mobiliser un électorat qui, a priori, serait juste resté chez lui le jour des élections.
Et là, on arrive avec une panique morale, quelque chose de très sensationnaliste. On stigmatise un groupe qui chercherait à détruire notre modèle de vie, notre universalisme à la française bien traditionnel.
Et voilà l'idée d'alors mobiliser un électorat qui se retrouverait dans cette panique morale. Est-ce que ça fait pas partie du jeu ?
Alors, en tout cas, la stratégie des guerres culturelles, au départ aux États-Unis, elle sert à ça.
On connaît l'histoire de la récupération de l'électorat évangéliste aux États-Unis par Ronald Reagan,
qui a décidé que c'était très important d'appuyer sur leurs fibres très conservatrices sur le plan des mœurs pour
réorienter justement le Parti républicain dans leur direction et obtenir leur vote, alors que c'était un électorat qui était plutôt
perçu comme étant désengagé et au vote plus ou moins éclaté précédemment.
Ensuite, est-ce que ça marche ? Ça, j'en sais rien. Mais à mon avis, la politique contient toujours des calculs qui sont : « Ben, comment est-ce que ça va pouvoir nous servir ?
» Et effectivement, je pense que quand
quelqu'un comme Jean-Michel Blanquer saute sur l'occasion de parler de wokisme et de tout ce que vous voulez, c'est parce qu'il perçoit que ça va lui permettre de se faire bien voir par une partie de l'opinion.
Et c'est possible, effectivement, qu'il se dise : « Ben, ça va permettre de faire voter pour moi des gens, enfin voter pour mon parti », parce que pas nécessairement pour lui, des gens qui seraient restés à la maison sans ça.
Ensuite, est-ce que ça a lieu ? Ça, j'en sais rien. Y a quelque chose qui surprenait beaucoup les chroniqueurs pendant la campagne présidentielle.
C'était le fait que malgré
le succès relatif en termes d'opinion publique de Fabien Roussel, qui lui se présentait justement comme étant, ben le militant de gauche anti-
wokiste, anti ce qu'il appelait la gauche cojon, qui mange des graines de chia et qui se nourrit de tofu-
Fabien Roussel qui parle beaucoup de sa consommation de viande, d'ailleurs.
Oui. Et ben, que lui était donc très populaire. Il était à la tête notamment d'un barème qui m'a un peu amusé, qui était le barème du candidat avec lequel les gens voudraient le plus boire une bière.
J'avoue que moi-même, c'est mon choix en la matière. Et également, avait une opinion très positive, mais ne décollait pas dans les sondages ni, on l'a vu à la fin, dans les votes effectifs.
Et je ne sais pas, au fond, s'il y a beaucoup de gens dans le monde réel qui rentrent dans l'isoloir et qui se disent : « Ce candidat-là, moi, j'ai envie de voter pour lui parce qu'il aime pas les végétariens.
» Je ne pense pas que ça soit le cas. Et donc, ben manifestement, c'est pas ça qui a influencé les urnes, du coup, sur cette élection, il semblerait.
Ça veut pas dire que ce sera pas le cas dans une future élection, mais oui, je pense que quand des politiques se saisissent de cet objet, c'est parce qu'ils y perçoivent la possibilité
d'agir dans un sens qui leur semble cohérent sur le plan de l'opinion, oui, bien sûr.
Mmm-hmm. Alors, vous employez à plusieurs reprises dans le livre la notion de backlash, hein, qu'on attribue donc à Susan Faludi.
Donc cette idée, pour replacer un petit peu le—
c'est l'idée qu'y a un mouvement presque automatique, systématique à chaque fois qu'on observe des progressions en termes de droits pour les minorités, par exemple les femmes, par exemple
les minorités sexuelles,
une répression systématique, un agacement de la part des dominants, des hommes blancs cis hétérosexuels.
Et donc, est-ce que vous estimez que ces discours anti-woke se placent là-dedans ? Est-ce qu'on peut considérer que c'est une forme de backlash ?
Oui, absolument. Et ce qui est intéressant, c'est que la notion et le travail de Susan Faludi ont souvent été perçus comme étant, en fait, y a presque un, entre guillemets, juste retour de bâton.
Alors, elle ne partage pas du tout cette idée, hein, mais c'est mécanique. C'est-à-dire que on va trop loin dans un sens et donc on retourne un peu dans un autre.
Et puis on ira ensuite trop loin dans ce sens. Et puis voilà, y a une espèce d'aller-retour.
Ce que cette vision-là, qui n'est pas la vision que présente Faludi dans son livre, puisqu'elle insiste justement sur le fait qu'il y a des activistes derrière ça,
eh ben, ce que cette vision-là tend à cacher, c'est la réalité de ces activistes.
Et nos amis les anti-woke, ils ont un peu une forme, un petit peu une petite fièvre un peu populiste qui consiste à vouloir cacher le fait qu'ils sont, ben eux, des activistes.
Moi, je considère pas le terme comme une insulte du tout
et j'essaie de les analyser comme tels. C'est-à-dire des gens qui veulent faire aller l'opinion dans un certain sens et qui la travaillent et qui disent : « Bah regardez, les antiracistes vont trop loin.
Il faut aller contre cette folie antiraciste. Les féministes vont trop loin, les LGBT vont trop loin, tout le monde va trop loin.
Et donc il faut aller dans le sens inverse. » Et parfois même, ce backlash peut être préventif. Il me semble que sur le plan, par exemple, de ce qu'on a appelé le racialisme, entre guillemets, à l'université, ça a beaucoup été le cas.
Éric Fassin indiquait à juste titre
qu'il n'y a pas en France de département de recherche, de laboratoire de recherche consacré à la sociologie critique de la race, c'est-à-dire de la façon dont les gens sont assignés à des groupes.
Évidemment, on n'analyse pas les races comme étant des trucs qui existeraient, entre guillemets, pour de vrai. On les analyse comme des—
Des constructions sociales.
...des phénomènes sociaux, des constructions sociales. Et il indiquait qu'il n'y a pas de département consacré à cette question-là dans une
émission, je cite La Scène, et où, en face de lui, justement, ben le sociologue canadien Mathieu Bock-Côté, que je citais tout à l'heure, disait : « Voilà, le réel n'a pas eu lieu, on n'a rien le droit de dire, etc.
» Et il semblerait que si la question qu'on se pose, c'est : est-ce qu'il y a trop de sociologie de la race en France
? Le fait qu'il n'y ait pas de département consacré à cette question, ça semble être indicateur du fait que non, on n'est probablement pas allé trop loin.
Donc voilà, effectivement, ce backlash peut être préventif, c'est-à-dire dire : « Finalement, l'imagination même de la possibilité du fait que ça ait lieu justifie déjà le fait de faire comme si c'était déjà allé trop loin. »
Mais vous rejoignez un petit peu, j'allais faire un parallèle avec ce que David Paternotte nous expliquait, quand je l'ai reçu dans ce podcast en janvier dernier.
Lui a tendance à plutôt rejeter l'idée du backlash. Il n'y croit pas tellement, justement parce que,
ce que lui il explique, c'est que les historiens montrent qu'il n'y a pas vraiment d'automaticité dans l'histoire et que justement, ce que vous disiez, c'est que,
la réaction, parfois, peut précéder l'action.
Ça contredit un petit peu la définition qui n'est pas très clairement, comme vous le disiez, très clairement établie, très clairement définie dans ce que Susan Faludi a proposé.
Mais donc lui, il n'est pas très fan de ce concept, mais on comprend, oui, que voilà, vous apportez quelques nuances importantes à ce niveau-là, oui.
Moi, je suis pas dans une démarche qui est similaire à celle de monsieur Paternotte, qui est quelqu'un que j'admire beaucoup, a priori, et qui m'a justement fait part de cette inquiétude,
quand on a discuté de mon projet de bouquin.
Il est dans les remerciements du livre parce qu'on a eu un entretien à ce sujet. Moi, je n'écris pas ici un livre de sociologie et donc j'ai choisi de parler de backlash, tout simplement parce que c'est un mot qui parle à beaucoup de gens.
C'est vrai.
Effectivement, si j'étais dans une démarche scientifique, peut-être que je ferais plus attention à l'usage de ce concept, précisément pour cette raison.
Ou alors, je consacrerais un chapitre au fait de le discuter et d'aller faire une revue de la littérature. Là, le but était d'aller parler au plus grand nombre, entre guillemets, et par conséquent, il me semble que le terme de backlash, voilà,
les gens savent à quoi ça fait référence, donc ça me va de l'utiliser dans ce contexte-là.
Mais c'est très clair, merci. On évoquait, il y a quelques instants donc, le fait que
au fond, quand on regarde le fond des discours anti-woke, il y a régulièrement cette volonté de se poser en victime.
On évoquait il y a un instant la notion des constructions sociales. Il y a l'idée dans leur discours que le wokisme, l'intersectionnalité, tout ça, c'est construit.
Et ce qui est remis en question, mais c'est finalement l'ordre naturel, c'est ce qu'on ne peut pas remettre en question.
J'ai l'impression qu'il y a souvent cette volonté de présenter les discours woke de manière très
abstraite, très caricaturée, sans jamais interroger, voilà, des personnes qui se revendiqueraient intersectionnelles ou antiracistes ou féministes, etc.
Et cette volonté de très souvent caricaturer. Comment est-ce qu'on explique ça ?
Je pense qu'on l'explique par le fait que c'est possible, tout simplement. C'est la nature du pouvoir. Vous savez, si vous pouvez faire quelque chose, vous allez, sans être puni, vous allez le faire.
Là-dessus, moi, je pense qu'il y a effectivement un problème de déontologie médiatique, qui se présente. C'est-à-dire, si--
il y a plusieurs cas où je cite, par exemple, des articles qui mentent en fait, qui mentent tout simplement.
Moi, je pense au traitement qui a été réservé à une dame qui s'appelle madame Gourba,
dans une chronique sur France Culture de monsieur Brice Couturier concernant la critique qu'elle avait faite d'un roman, American Dirt, et qui a été présentée comme étant une personne qui a voulu censurer ce,
ce livre en vertu du fait qu'il n'avait pas été écrit par une Sud-Américaine.
Et quand on lisait sa critique, c'était une critique qui était extrêmement acerbe, mais qui ne disait pas ça. Donc, là-dessus, il y a une question de déontologie.
C'est si on a la possibilité de dire tout et n'importe quoi et de distordre les propos des uns et des autres sans qu'ils aient évidemment la possibilité de répondre, eh ben, on va le faire.
Pourquoi pas ? Alors maintenant, comment se fait-il que ces, comment dire, personnes ne soient pas davantage invitées pour débattre ?
Il me semble que ce n'est pas qu'une question de
De facilité de parole
...de censure. À mon avis, ça doit être-- ouais, non, ça doit être très facile, en fait, 'fin c'est en fait très facile d'accéder au débat.
C'est aussi le fait qu'on parle beaucoup d'universitaires. Et force est de constater, ça, c'est le journaliste Mathieu Molard qui faisait la réflexion récemment dans un,
dans un événement sur ce sujet, que l'université, en France en particulier, n'a pas l'habitude d'envoyer des gens entre guillemets au front pour tenir le crachoir dans des débats.
Et donc, et moi-même, j'en aurais d'ailleurs très peur. Je jette la pierre à personne là-dessus.
J'allais dire : c'est aussi votre endroit, de parler ?
Alors, je le fais, mais sans aller dans ces fameux débats.
Oui, c'est ça, voilà, c'est plus-
C'est ça. Et j'ai, moi, j'ai-
C'est plus pacifique chez Septante Minutes Avec, c'est plus doux.
Tout à fait. Mais effectivement, il y a la question de dire : bon-- et là, c'est aussi lié à des conditions de travail, etc.
C'est pas que les gens sont feignants et lâches, c'est que, ben, c'est pas félicité, c'est pas bien vu.
On est-- tout le monde est surchargé de travail, mes collègues le sont tout autant les uns que les autres.
Mais voilà, il y a aussi pas une habitude d'aller donner la réplique dans ce type de contexte. Donc il y a ça aussi qui joue, me semble-t-il.
Toujours quand on regarde, voilà, le fond de ce discours anti-woke,
il y a une forme d'opposition entre une gauche identitaire, wokiste, déconstructionniste, postmoderne et un champ politique constitué de gens normaux.
Donc finalement, le woke, ce serait l'opposé de ce qui est la norme.
Ouais, alors, ça, c'est la théorie des deux gauches irréconciliables, mais force est de constater qu'en fait,
ben les deux gauches irréconciliables, en fait, c'est d'un côté la gauche et d'un autre côté, ben des personnes qui ont fait alliance avec,
a minima le centre, a maxima la droite.
La question pour moi, elle est beaucoup plus : il y a une gauche qui est une gauche technicienne, technocratique, c'est-à-dire une gauche de ministères, une gauche d'appareils,
une gauche qui est passée par l'ENA, une gauche qui a obtenu des postes de,
dans des grands ministères,
qui a fait sa carrière en fait beaucoup par le centre.
Et puis il y a une gauche qui est proche des mouvements sociaux. Ce qui est décrit systématiquement comme étant le,
la déconstruction, le postmodernisme ou tout ce que vous voulez, ce sont les mouvements sociaux contemporains, qu'ils soient syndicaux, antiracistes, féministes, liés aux luttes LGBT, locaux ou autres.
Et ces gens-là, en fait, qui sont décrits comme étant anormaux et bizarres. Effectivement, c'est un secteur de la société qui est, ben, engagé et donc qui est spécifique. Maintenant,
je constate toutefois que
ce qui est présenté comme étant la gauche du réel, elle a beaucoup de mal à, 'fin, elle a beaucoup de mal à mettre des pieds dans la rue, quand il s'agit de se mobiliser, quand il s'agit de faire autre chose que de faire des causeries,
dans des grands hebdomadaires ou dans des grands quotidiens, ben il y a pas grand monde.
Alors, ensuite, il y a une image de normalité qui est utilisée. Et ça, vous avez raison. Une figure que je cite fréquemment, qui est souvent utilisée dans ce sens-là, c'est la figure de la féministe à cheveux bleus qui serait une personne, voilà,
complètement déconnectée des réalités, qui serait très horrible, qui serait complètement dans l'idéologie, etc.
Alors déjà, moi, j'ai pas connaissance du fait qu'avoir les cheveux bleus, ça discrédite votre propos. Et ensuite,
j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'elle dit, parce que fréquemment, en fait, quand on écoute le discours de la fameuse féministe à cheveux bleus, eh ben en réalité, c'est elle qui a,
c'est elle qui a les chiffres de son côté, c'est elle qui a les faits de son côté et qui a en face d'elle des gens qui sont dans une mauvaise foi totale.
Littéralement, la personne-
Tout ça est un brin caricatural, puisque je ne sais pas quel-- je suis sûr que je pourrais vous trouver une féministe à cheveux bleus qui ne sait pas trop de quoi elle parle, mais bon-
Bien sûr
...on va résumer avec ça. Toutes les féministes à cheveux bleus ont leurs chiffres et savent de quoi elles parlent pour les droits de sens.
Mais là, je fais référence à une anecdote qui est bien particulière et qui est presque le point de départ pour moi de cette petite expérience.
Il y a une image qui est connue sur Internet comme un mème qui s'appelle la Triggered Feminist, qui est une femme qui est représentée comme ça avec une expression de colère sur le visage comme étant la féministe irrationnelle, etc.
Il s'avère qu'on peut retrouver l'extrait, la manifestation d'où est issue cette image, sur YouTube.
En réalité, cette dame était en train d'avoir une discussion avec un militant pro-Trump sur la question des agressions sexuelles,
était en train de présenter très calmement ses arguments en citant des statistiques et a eu le malheur de faire un visage un peu effectivement rigolo à un moment donné et d'être donc,
sélectionnée, extraite et transformée en image de femme irrationnelle.
Et tous les commentaires dans la vidéo disent : « Je suis vachement déçu, je suis venu pour voir une-
Une féministe énervée qui ne sait pas de quoi elle parle.
Voilà, une féministe énervée qui s'étrangle de rage. Et en fait, j'ai face à moi une dame tout à fait rationnelle, qui est en fait la personne qui avait le bon côté du bâton dans cette interaction.
C'est à ça que je pensais. Et donc ce côté de caricature de dire : « Ben nous, on est les gens normaux et eux sont les irrationnels », c'est effectivement quelque chose auquel tient beaucoup ce mouvement, ouais.
Ouais, et l'exemple que vous donnez est très emblématique de, mais finalement, oui, de cette,
façon dont les paniques morales, en l'occurrence La Panique Woke,
fait usage comme à peu près tout de nos jours, mais de ces nouveaux médias que sont par exemple les mèmes, les mèmes,
pour circuler sur les réseaux de manière très très caricaturale où on, voilà, comme vous disiez, on prend une photo d'une personne et on,
on lui met un texte
complètement autre, complètement ridicule en dessous du visage.
Et ça, ça sert à mobiliser un certain imaginaire, à conforter dans nos certitudes, etc. Donc c'est-
Si je peux juste me permettre de faire une remarque concernant ce point, c'est que là-dessus, je pense que c'est là que se trouvent les limites du debunking.
Moi, j'en fais un petit peu, du debunking, dans mon livre. Je dis : « Ah non, en fait, quand on regarde ce qui s'est passé, c'était ça ».
Mais il ne faut pas être dupe du fait que souvent, en fait, on a face à nous des gens qui ne croient pas à ce qu'ils disent et qui sont en train de plaisanter, qui sont en train de caricaturer, de se moquer et de pointer du doigt.
Et c'est comme je le dis dans le bouquin,
dans la blague du kangourou qui fait du scooter, si vous entendez cette blague et que vous faites comme remarque qu'en fait, dans la vie, les kangourous ne font pas de scooter, tout le monde va vous regarder de travers. Parce que
si on est en train de faire la blague sur la féministe à cheveux bleus qui perd ses moyens et que vous dites : « Ben en fait non,
les féministes à cheveux bleus ne perdent pas nécessairement leurs moyens et en fait, c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça ».
Si tout le monde est ici pour faire des blagues sur les méchantes féministes, personne n'en a rien à faire de savoir s'ils ont
effectivement ou non perdu leurs moyens, puisque tout le monde est là pour se payer une bonne tranche de rigolade.
Et c'est ça qui est recommandé.
Si vous lisez par exemple la note de la Fondation pour l'innovation politique, qui est un think tank de droite français qui a produit une note en deux parties qui s'appelle « Face au wokisme
», eh bien, les recommandations, c'est : il faut se moquer d'eux.
Et donc, là-dessus, il faut pas se faire avoir en pensant que quand quelqu'un est en train de se moquer de vous ou de quelqu'un d'autre, il est en train de présenter un argument rationnel auquel il faudrait répondre de façon rationnelle.
Alors, on arrive tout doucement au bout de notre entretien, Alex Mahoudeau. On a pu traiter ensemble des raisons pour lesquelles ces choses sont autant mises en avant dans les médias.
On a pu discuter de la nature de ces discours, du côté cyclique de ces discours, de-- on a pu évoquer la notion de backlash.
On a pu faire un tour des questions qui sont évoquées dans votre livre. Donc, je rappelle, publié aux Éditions Textuel, La Panique Woke.
Si je devais vous demander les réponses à proposer face à cette panique woke, qu'est-ce qu'on en fait finalement, face au constat qu'on a pu établir ensemble aujourd'hui ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Alors, si je le savais, je serais déjà roi des États-Unis. De façon plus sérieuse, je pense qu'il faut faire feu de tout bois.
Je pense que le public n'a pas une réponse unique, il y a pas une recette unique à ce type de phénomène.
Il faut peut-être continuer à avoir des investigations très scientifiques, très sérieuses, très rigoureuses dans ce qui se passe.
Il faut avoir des textes qui sont ce que j'ai essayé de faire, c'est-à-dire un peu entre les deux. Il faut avoir des gens-- je pense qu'il faut pas hésiter à aller sur le terrain de la rigolade, de la moquerie.
Même, c'est vrai que parfois, il y a de quoi rire. Quand on voit une personne, par exemple, comme Jordan Peterson, qui est le grand modèle, le psychologue canadien qui s'effondre en larmes récemment parce qu'il a,
été absolument terrorisé par le fait que les gens disent que le réchauffement climatique est une réalité.
Mais d'un autre côté, il a aussi fondu en larmes à cause de, me semble-t-il, c'était Pinocchio, précédemment dans sa carrière.
Donc bon, voilà, c'est un personnage très sérieux. Il faut pas hésiter à y aller, sur ce type de domaine. Et puis à côté de ça, il faut-
Si on veut parler du fait que c'est un personnage très sérieux, il y a de nombreux exemples. On peut parler du fait que-
Oui
...il explique que l'anatomie, je crois, humaine est très similaire à celle du homard. Et donc, il fait des comparaisons-
...avec le homard pour nous expliquer la masculinité, le-
Ouais
...les hormones, etc. C'est, ouais, c'est un professeur de psychologie canadien qui, effectivement, a construit au fil des années une communauté, ben, on va dire masculiniste, très conservatrice.
Oui, et qui est beaucoup basée sur l'idée qu'il faut être--
qu'il faut se durcir face au monde et supporter le fait que des gens disent des choses qu'on n'a pas envie d'entendre, tout en étant lui-même systématiquement scandalisé pour tout et n'importe quoi.
Et à propos du ridicule, donc c'est-- et à propos d'être quelqu'un de dur et de durci, de mâle et de viril, etc.
Ouais
...ce qu'il a fait, c'est que je crois qu'il consomme exclusivement du bœuf cru. Est-ce que je-- je sais pas si je dis des bêtises.
Pas cru, non. Non, non, pas cru. C'est sa f-- alors, je sais pas si c'est son cas à lui ou pas. Oui, il a un régime, enfin sa fille, en fait, recommande un régime à base de viande de bœuf et de,
Et mange pas de légumes apparemment
...une épice particulière, mais qui m'échappe. Et donc il faudrait manger ça, ce serait excellent pour la santé. Ouais, tout à fait.
C'est ça. Ouais, c'est ça.
Mais bon, ça, c'est-
Voilà. Et, mais il a des problèmes de santé à cause de ça, des trucs vraiment très très graves.
Son état de santé est-
N'en doute pas
...catastrophique-
Mais là-dessus-
...probablement lié à son régime très particulier.
Mais là-dessus, il faut aussi, voilà, savoir, là, pour le coup, faire preuve d'une vraie empathie, puisque une des choses pour lesquelles Jordan Peterson a été vigoureusement moqué,
c'était le fait qu'il a souffert vraiment d'un très gros problème du fait d'arrêter un traitement sur la base de benzodiazépines, donc de Xanax,
et qui est un médicament qui,
à grande dose et mal contrôlé, peut provoquer un manque et des souffrances réelles.
Et là-dessus, je pense qu'il faut savoir par contre être-- se rappeler que voilà, la lutte politique s'arrête à un endroit, il faut être humain.
Bien sûr.
Et que voilà, on a des gens autour de nous qui souffrent de ça et il faut savoir le respecter. Enfin, pour finir de répondre à votre question,
je pense que prendre conscience au sein de la gauche du fait que, ben en fait, la fameuse féministe à cheveux bleus, la fameuse néo-féministe intersectionnelle, la fameuse personne trans,
la fameuse personne queer ou gay,
les syndicalistes qui foutent le bordel,
et les bobos gauchos, baba cool de la fac de lettres, eh ben souvent, ils sont plutôt de notre côté que du côté inverse, en fait.
Peut-être qu'ils ont des modes de vie qui surprennent, peut-être qu'ils ont des esthétiques qui surprennent, peut-être que parfois, on s'engueule avec eux.
C'est possible. Moi, je m'engueule, je suis dans une organisation politique, je me crêpe le chignon avec des camarades sur des questions de cette nature et d'autres, mais on est du même côté de la barricade.
Et au contraire, il me semble que c'est intéressant de noter que, eh ben, à l'automne 2020. 2021, excusez-moi.
Quelle est l'organisation qui a organisé une table ronde sur le danger de la culture woke pendant son université d'été ?
Eh bien, il s'agissait du MEDEF. Le MEDEF, je les connais depuis un certain temps, dans les luttes sociales dans lesquelles j'ai eu l'occasion de m'investir, n'étaient pas mes amis.
Non, non, juste pour rappeler aux auditeurs belges, le MEDEF, c'est donc l'espèce de syndicat des entrepreneurs et des patrons, quoi, en France.
Tout à fait, ouais. Le syndicat des patrons qui a des positions qui sont très libérales, très autoritaires, très de droite.
Et donc, là-dessus, je pense qu'il y a un message, moi, que je souhaite envoyer, hein, à la partie de la gauche qui s'inquiète des fameux wokistes.
C'est peut-être que c'est des gens que vous trouvez bizarres, mais c'est vos gens que vous trouvez bizarres. C'est des gens que vous trouvez bizarres qui sont dans votre camp.
Il va falloir que vous vous les coltinez parce qu'en fait, c'est vos camarades. Et donc, ben, ouais, il va falloir se—
Donc ça, c'est vraiment une lecture marxiste, lutte des classes.
Oui.
Est-ce que ça parle à tout le monde ? Je ne suis pas sûr.
Non, mais j'ai,
j'ai envie de dire la même chose à tout le monde là-dessus. Moi, j'ai une vision qui est de la lutte des classes au sens élargi ou de ce que les anarchistes sud-américains appelleraient les classes et secteurs
opprimés, c'est-à-dire qui inclut aussi, hein, les communautés locales, les minorités, etc.
Et c'est de dire : « Ben, on gagne ensemble ou on perd ensemble ». Moi, je m'inscris dans une perspective qui est une perspective de gauche.
Pour le coup, je ne m'en cache pas. Et je pense que ouais, y a une forme de snobisme qu'il faut savoir rejeter, en effet.
Très bien. Alex Mahoudeau, merci beaucoup pour ces 70 minutes passées ensemble.
Merci à vous.
Et donc, je rappelle votre livre, La Panique Woke, publié aux Éditions Textuel : Anatomie d'une offensive réactionnaire.
Je mettrai le lien en description. À très bientôt, merci.
Merci.
Voilà, j'espère que ça vous a plu et que vous avez eu l'occasion d'apprendre plein de choses. On se retrouve dans deux semaines pour une interview, cette fois liée à l'autisme.
Et normalement, peu de temps après, on aura un épisode sur un sujet que j'avais annoncé il y a déjà longtemps, l'antisémitisme.
Je vous fais plein de bisous. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à Septante Minutes Avec si ce n'est pas déjà fait. N'oubliez pas de partager ce podcast, s'il vous plaît.
Et je vous dis à très bientôt. Salut !